let me ask you about some features yeah
so we talked about obviously indentation
that it's a type language or optionally
typed
is that the right way to say it it's
either optionally or progressively or
aggressively I think so so so people
have very strong opinions on the right
word to use yeah I don't know I look
forward to your letters uh so there's
the the VAR versus let but let is for
constants uh VAR is an optional uh yeah
varm makes it mutable so you can
reassign okay uh then there's uh
function overloading oh okay yeah so I
mean there's a lot of source of
happiness for me but function
overloading that's
um I guess is that is that for
performance or is that why does python
not have function overloading
so I can speculate so um python is a
dynamic language the way it works is
that um
uh python Objective C are actually
very similar worlds if you ignore syntax
and so uh Objective C is straight line
derived from small talk
a really venerable interesting language
that much of the world has forgotten
about but the people that remember it
love it generally and the way that Small
Talk Works is that every object has a
dictionary in it and the dictionary maps
from the name of a function or the name
of a value within an object to its
implementation
and so the way you call a method in
Objective C is you say go look up the
way I call Foos I go look up Foo I get a
pointer to the function back and then I
call it okay that's what python works
right and so now the problem with that
is that the dictionary within a python
object all the keys are strings
and it's a dictionary yeah so you can
only have one entry per name you think
it's as simple as that I think it's as
simple as that and so now why do they
never fix this like why do they not
change it to not be a dictionary like do
other things
um well you don't really have to in
Python because it's Dynamic and so you
can say I get into the function now if I
got past an integer do some Dynamic
tests for it if it's a string or do
another thing there's another additional
challenge which is even if you did
support overloading you're saying okay
well here's a version of a function for
integers and a function for Strings well
you'd have even if you could put it in
that dictionary you'd have to have the
caller do the dispatch and so every time
you call the function you'd have to say
like is it an integer is it a string and
so you have to figure out where to do
that test and so in a dynamic language
overloading is something you General you
don't have to have so
but now you get into a type language and
you know in Python if you subscript with
an integer
then you get typically one element out
of a collection if you subscript with a
range you get a different thing out
right and so often in type languages
you'll want to be able to express the
fact that cool I have different Behavior
depending on what I actually pass into
this thing if you can model that it can
make it safer and more predictable and
faster and like all these things it
somehow feels safer yes but also feels
empowering like in terms of clarity like
you don't have to design hold different
functions yeah well this is also one of
the the challenges with the existing
python typing systems is that in
practice like you take subscript like in
practice a lot of these functions they
don't have one signature right they
actually have different behavior in
different cases and so this is why it's
difficult to like retrofit this into
existing python code and make it
uh play well with typing you kind of
have to design for that